Timoney so here we have antimony okay
antimony you can see through the bottle
is a really quite nice metallic element
so antimony is in the same group as
arsenic and is a rather silvery metal
that looks like arsenic it is used quite
widely in the electronics industry and
usually it is put into electronics by
taking the hydrogen compound SB h3
steeping and decomposing it and you get
a film of antimony plus hydrogen which
gives away I'm not actually going to
take it out of this bottle though
because there are some severe or some
really quite damaging toxicological
problems so it's safely contained inside
the bottle in this seal but we see a
wonderful sample of antimony there it's
about 50 grams of antimony in that very
small bottle we could get into a lot of
trouble with that that's evil stuff
anton is also used in mixtures with
indium to make indium antimonide which
is quite an interesting semiconductor
material which can be used in
transistors and the like and antimony
also has quite an important role it's
compounds as a catalyst in making the so
called CFCs the compounds that are in
refrigerators and which caused such a
scare environmental scare in the 1970s
and 80s because CFCs when they get into
the atmosphere can destroy the ozone
layer and cause skin cancer and so on